Now, remember that Marla actually
receives most of her care from
specialists.
Each of them is focused on the one organ
or body system they were trained in and
they care for.
Remember Doctor Johnson, the
endocrinologist who cares for Marla's
diabetes, and Doctor Jones, the lung
specialist to whom she was referred.
Each of them will probably be interested
in different data from Marla's very
large chart.
This would include subjective
information Marla has provided and
objective information from her
prior physical exams, lab tests, or
other studies.
Each of them will
prescribe medications and
other treatments that are specific to
the disease that they're managing.
Current EMRs generally
don't understand this and
don't automatically
make this distinctions.